they have walked long distances through
some of the harshest conditions in the
world no matter how difficult they
Journey these migrants marching across
Mexico say they're determined to stop
only once they reach the United States
we don't have any other alternative than
leaving from here and to keep moving
forward we won't give up all of us want
to get to the United States to fight for
a better future for my daughter here and
another one I left in Honduras
fleeing violence and poverty in Central
America thousands of migrants walk
together for safety to reach Mexico each
year
we have to move and keep aiming for our
Dream because I left with a dream my
wife is four months pregnant this is my
dream to arrive in the United States and
give it all to my daughter
this group has mostly Venezuelans who
flew to Panama or Costa Rica then it's
the long journey North on foot
they're aiming to reach a Mexico City in
around 10 days
this is not just a search for better
opportunities these people are angry
about a fire at a Detention Center in
Mexico last month that killed 40
migrants
now they carry crosses and Banners to
remember those who'll never see the U.S
now we have decided to move forward in
this journey because of the 40 people
who died there who were set on fire the
officials are murderers they don't want
the migrants from our countries and we
want Justice
even if they make it to the U.S border
entering the United States is not easy
tough immigration policies are making it
harder for migrants to claim Asylum
and after spending days and weeks on the
road these children and their families
May well be told to go back
Andrea van wyk Al Jazeera
Australia has launched its biggest
defense shaker